Ed Ryder plays the trumpet. He was sentenced to Graterford Penitentiary in Pennsylvania for 20 years for a murder it was later shown he did not commit. He played jazz when he was in prison. He played jazz when he got out. And he says that it is a completely different experience playing jazz to inmates.
埃德·莱德是一位小号手。他曾在宾夕法尼亚州的格雷特福德监狱被判入狱20年，罪名是一项后来被证明并非他所犯的谋杀案。他在监狱里时演奏爵士乐。出狱后，他依然演奏爵士乐。他说，为囚犯们演奏爵士乐是一种截然不同的体验。
Oh. Inmates are the most critical people in the world. They criticize anything you do. And you know, you try to play for these guys, but you know, nothing's pleasing to them. If you can play for a Graterford audience, you don't even look for an applause. Just as long as they don't boo you, you're all right.
哦，囚犯是世界上最挑剔的人。他们会批评你做的任何事。你知道，你试图为这些家伙演奏，但你知道，他们什么都不满意。如果你能在格雷特福德的观众面前演奏，你甚至不会指望掌声。只要他们不嘘你，你就谢天谢地了。
Well, you know, in prison, you have a lot of musicians. After all, musicians, they don't make no money. So I guess the first place you find them at is in prison.
嗯，你知道，在监狱里有很多音乐家。毕竟，音乐家赚不到钱。所以我猜你最先能找到他们的地方就是监狱。
But, Ed Ryder says, musicians and jazz fans in prison, their take on jazz gets warped. In a world where everybody's wary, everyone's always looking for weakness in someone else, in a world of strict rules, where everything always has to be just so-- it's like they take that ethic and they transfer it to one of the loosest, most improvisational art forms we have, jazz.
但是，埃德·莱德说，监狱里的音乐家和爵士乐迷，他们对爵士乐的理解被扭曲了。在一个每个人都充满戒心、每个人都在寻找他人弱点的世界里，在一个有着严格规则、一切都必须恰到好处的世界里——他们似乎把这种准则移植到了我们所拥有的最自由、最即兴的艺术形式之一——爵士乐上。
You can say that prisoners have a tendency to think like classical musicians would. You know, everything has to be perfect and exact, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], and everything has to be like that. You know, they'll be quick to criticize you, whether the chord is not right, or whether you didn't flatten the ninth, whether you didn't raise this fifth. You know, you guys didn't play the changes right. Although it might not have took away from the structure of the music.
你可以说囚犯们有一种像古典音乐家那样思考的倾向。你知道，一切都必须完美而精确，［听不清］，所有事情都必须是那样。你知道，他们会很快批评你，不管和弦是不是对的，还是你没降九音，或者你没升五音。你知道，你们这些家伙没把过门弹对。尽管这可能并没有破坏音乐的结构。
If they can't find nothing wrong with the music, they'll tell you, you know, you just didn't turn right. You know? When you had the horn up, you didn't hold it on a 45 degree angle. It didn't look right. The way you grinned when you left, whatever. You know? So they'll find something.
如果他们找不出音乐有什么不对劲，他们会告诉你，你只是转得不对。你知道吗？当你举起号角时，你没有把它保持在45度角。它看起来不对劲。你离开时咧嘴笑的方式，诸如此类。你知道吗？所以他们总能挑出毛病来。
Life in prison is not only different from life on the outside. It's a growing part of American culture, one of the fastest growing parts of this country. Thanks to tougher sentencing laws, mandatory minimum sentences, long terms for drug offenders, three strikes and you're out laws, laws bouncing 12 and 13 and 14 year olds into adult court for long adult sentences, the prison population has grown by 50% just since 1991. Well over a million people in state and federal prisons.
监狱生活不仅不同于外面的生活。它是美国文化中不断增长的一部分，是这个国家增长最快的部分之一。得益于更严厉的判决法律、强制性最低刑期、针对毒品犯罪的长期监禁、三振出局法，以及将12、13和14岁的孩子送进成人法庭判处长期成人刑期的法律，监狱人口仅自1991年以来就增长了50%。州和联邦监狱里的囚犯人数远超一百万。
Today on our program, their lives and the lives of the people close to them. Their families, their kids, many millions of others. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述他们的生活以及与他们亲近的人的生活。他们的家人、孩子，以及数以百万计的其他人的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One of our program today, I Mess with Texas. How one little radio show in Texas is doing something for inmates and their families that no one else in the state is able to do. Act Two, Mother's Day. What do you say to a five year old whose mother is in prison when he wants to know, is my mom a bad guy? Act Three, Who's Your Daddy? We have a guide for new prisoners written by an ex-con about how to choose a man to protect you while you're in the joint, and what you'll have to do for him in exchange for that protection. Act Four, Open Your Big Mouth. Rick Reynolds provides a case study about what happens when you go into a place, prison, where there are all sorts of codes about what you are never, ever, ever supposed to say, and what happens when you say every single one of them. Act Five, Color Bar. Former South African political prisoner Breyten Breytenbach on how prison changes all of your perceptions. Changes them in ways that last after you're released. Stay with us.
我们今天节目的第一幕，“我惹上德克萨斯了”。德克萨斯州的一个小广播节目是如何为囚犯及其家人做着该州其他任何人都做不到的事情。第二幕，“母亲节”。当一个五岁的孩子想知道“我的妈妈是个坏人吗”时，你该对他说什么？第三幕，“谁是你爸爸？”我们有一份由前囚犯编写的新囚犯指南，关于如何在监狱里选择一个保护你的人，以及为了这种保护你不得不为他做什么。第四幕，“张大你的嘴”。瑞克·雷诺兹提供了一个案例研究，讲述当你进入一个充斥着各种“绝对绝对不能说”的潜规则的监狱时，会发生什么，以及当你说了其中任何一条时会发生什么。第五幕，“色条”。前南非政治犯布雷顿·布雷滕巴赫讲述监狱如何改变你所有的感知。这种改变在获释后依然存在。请继续收听。
Act One, I Mess with Texas.
第一幕，“我惹上德克萨斯了”。
Over two decades ago, not long after he finished four years in Texas prison for robbery, Ray Hill drifted from job to job until he ended up at his local public radio station, KPFT in Houston. His time in the slammer-- in dreadful facilities, with no money or resources-- turned out to be the perfect preparation for a career in public broadcasting. And it was not long before he was running the place.
二十多年前，在因抢劫在德克萨斯州监狱服刑四年后不久，雷·希尔辗转于各种工作，最终来到了他当地的公共广播电台，休斯顿的KPFT。他在监狱里的时光——在没有钱或资源的糟糕设施中度过——竟然成了他公共广播事业的完美准备。没过多久，他就开始管理那个电台了。
As program director, he started his own show about the Texas prison system. It has become the leading muckraking voice in Texas, exposing graft and corruption in the state and federal facilities there. But it also does something else. Every Friday night, something that makes it one of the most unusual and remarkable radio programs in this country, though when Ray started, he had no idea that's where he was headed.
作为项目总监，他开始了自己关于德克萨斯监狱系统的节目。它已成为德克萨斯州主要的舆论监督声音，揭露了那里州和联邦设施中的贪污腐败。但它也做着另一件事。每个周五晚上，它都会做一些事情，使其成为这个国家最不同寻常、最引人注目的广播节目之一，尽管雷刚开始时并不知道他会走向何方。
I had envisioned interviewing judges, most of whom, local judges, I know. Prosecutors, criminal defense lawyers. And that's all I expected. And I gave myself an hour in time. And we were doing quite well with that. I was building an audience, especially among inmates.
我当时设想的是采访法官，他们中的大多数，当地的法官，我都认识。还有检察官、刑事辩护律师。这就是我所期待的一切。我给了自己一小时的时间。我们当时做得相当不错。我正在建立听众群，尤其是在囚犯中间。
And then one day I was coming in to do my show, and I'm minutes away from show time. And they say, Ray, you've got a telephone call. And I said, look, I'm fixed to go on the air. You know how we are. We don't take calls that close. And they say, but she's very insistent. So I put the receiver to my ear. And I said, lady, I've got about 30 seconds. What can I do for you?
有一天，我正准备做节目，离直播还有几分钟。他们说，雷，你有电话。我说，听着，我马上就要直播了。你知道我们是怎么回事。我们不接那种临近直播的电话。他们说，但她非常坚持。所以我把听筒贴在耳边。我说，女士，我只有大约30秒。我能为您做什么？
And what I heard was a distraught woman's voice, and weather sounds, and traffic sounds, and a really heartbreaking plea. She said that she had been saving money for three years or so to get enough resources together to go visit her son, and there had been an accident of some kind, and been forced off the road. And she wasn't going to be able to make it. But she knew he listened to my show. Would I please tell him that she loved him, and that she would work to get resources?
我听到的是一个心烦意乱的女人的声音，还有天气声、交通声，以及一个非常令人心碎的请求。她说她已经攒了大约三年的钱，才凑够资源去探望她的儿子，但路上出了某种事故，被挤出了车道。她无法成行了。但她知道他听我的节目。能不能请我告诉他，她爱他，她会努力挣钱？
And I suddenly realized, I do pretty damn good radio, but I can't do radio this good. And so I got the number and called her back. And after I did my introduction, I put her on directly.
我突然意识到，我做的广播节目相当不错，但我做不到这么好的广播。所以我记下了号码并回拨给她。在做了介绍后，我直接让她通了话。
It's interesting, because now that is the entire show. Most of it is people talking to their loved ones in prison.
很有趣，因为现在这就是整个节目了。其中大部分是人们与他们在监狱里的亲人交谈。
And they're obviously not even aware that I am there or don't care. Once in a while, somebody will have something to say to me. But they go right on and talk to Johnny.
他们显然根本没意识到我在那儿，或者不在乎。偶尔有人会对我说点什么。但他们会直接继续和约翰尼说话。
Hi, John. This is Cookie. I hope you've had a wonderful, happy Christmas day. I'm at home at my apartment now. and I made them bring me home yesterday, because I wasn't about to miss out on calling you tonight.
嗨，约翰。我是库基。我希望你度过了一个美妙、快乐的圣诞节。我现在在家里，在我的公寓里。我让他们昨天带我回来，因为我绝不能错过今晚给你打电话的机会。
Hello, Ray. Merry Christmas to you.
你好，雷。祝你圣诞快乐。
Merry Christmas, Nanny. That's two weeks in a row you got in. So you go ahead.
圣诞快乐，南妮。这是你连续两周打进来了。你接着说吧。
OK. Eddie Jr., this is Nanny. I'm going to tell you Merry Christmas and Happy New Year's to you. And I got a gift from your son. His mother gave it to me, him and [UNINTELLIGIBLE], his little brother. They gave me a little jewelry box. A little round jewelry deal. You pick the lid up, and you can put jewelry or anything in it, really. It's real pretty. And I want to tell you I love you. You take care, OK?
好的。小埃迪，我是南妮。我要祝你圣诞快乐，新年快乐。我收到了你儿子的礼物。他妈妈给我的，他和［听不清］，他的小弟弟。他们给了我一个小珠宝盒。一个小圆形的珠宝盒。你掀开盖子，可以在里面放珠宝或其他任何东西，真的。很漂亮。我想告诉你我爱你。照顾好自己，好吗？
Hi Junior. This is Mami. How you doing? I hope you had a real nice merry Christmas. We'll see you tomorrow morning. So go to bed early, so we can see you tomorrow.
嗨，朱尼尔。我是妈妈。你怎么样？我希望你过了一个非常愉快的圣诞节。我们明天早上见。早点睡觉，这样我们明天就能见到你了。
Hi Dad. When I go back to school, I got a new schedule. I'll be in shop. And I got my bike. Thanks. Real nice.
嗨，爸爸。当我回到学校时，我有了一个新课表。我会去实习车间。我拿到了我的自行车。谢谢。真的很棒。
Hello, son. How you doing? We're doing OK. It's kind of cold. But everything's going well.
你好，儿子。你怎么样？我们挺好的。天气有点冷。但一切都很顺利。
Ray, explain why it is that people would call a radio show instead of simply calling directly or getting a call from their loved ones in prison.
雷，解释一下为什么人们会给广播节目打电话，而不是直接拨打电话或从他们在监狱的亲人那里接到电话。
In Texas, we don't have telephones in prisons.
在德克萨斯州，我们的监狱里没有电话。
And so right now, if I'm a prisoner in Texas, there's no way I can ever get a call in home?
所以现在，如果我是德克萨斯州的囚犯，我就没有任何办法能接到家里的电话吗？
Well, if you're a prisoner, and if you're a trustee in a Texas prison, and you're on very, very good behavior, you can get one opportunity for a telephone call home for five minutes every 90 days. And if you're in the free world, like my callers, you can't call at all.
嗯，如果你是囚犯，如果你是德克萨斯监狱里的受托人，并且表现非常好，你每90天可以获得一次五分钟的通话机会。如果你是在自由世界，就像我的听众一样，你根本打不进去。
This is Marcy for Chance. And I had a very thankful day for Thanksgiving. I was just thankful that I survived Texas and arrived alive in my little hovel. Felt like a big fish in a big pond. Not much to say. A lot happening. Glad to be home. Feel like Dorothy. I just wanted to let you know I arrived alive. All is well. Taking care of the home front. And I miss you. I love you. Bye.
这是玛西给钱斯打的。我度过了一个非常感恩的感恩节。我只是很感激我活过了德克萨斯，并且活着回到了我的小窝。感觉就像大池塘里的一条大鱼。没什么可说的。发生了不少事。很高兴回家。感觉像多萝西。我只是想让你知道我活着回来了。一切都好。照顾好了家里。我想你。我爱你。再见。
Ray, one of the things that's striking about this is how it's almost like a real conversation, how somebody calls up not exactly sure what they want to say, and then just launches into talking.
雷，这件事令人震惊的一点是，它几乎就像一场真正的对话，有人打进来时并不确切知道自己想说什么，然后就开始滔滔不绝。
Well, Marcy's not an unusual caller. Marcy calls regularly. This particular call, she had come to Texas to visit. She's from out of state. When you visit from out of state in Texas, you get a four hour visit. And if you're a spouse, it's a contact visit. If you're not a spouse it's still a four hour visit, but you have no contact. And that likely was the only quality time she got to spend with him in several years.
嗯，玛西不是普通的听众。玛西经常打进来。这次通话，她曾到德克萨斯探监。她是外州人。在德克萨斯州，从外州探监，你有四个小时的探视时间。如果你是配偶，那是接触式探视。如果你不是配偶，依然有四个小时的探视时间，但没有身体接触。那很可能是她在几年里能和他共度的唯一高质量时光。
Let me ask you to talk about the range of what people call and say.
请你谈谈人们打进来的电话范围和内容。
Well, almost a third of the calls are honey, we make it home all right. Or we're going to visit Saturday.
嗯，几乎三分之一的电话是“亲爱的，我们平安到家了”或者“我们周六去探监”。
Hi, this is Claudia from Houston.
嗨，这是休斯顿的克劳迪娅。
Yes, ma'am.
是的，女士。
I was calling for my husband Steve in the Terrell unit. Babe, I was calling to tell you I'm not going to be able to come this weekend, because they put me to work. I wasn't able to get the weekend off. I was thinking I would come to see you Saturday, but I wasn't able to.
我打电话是给在特雷尔单位服刑的丈夫史蒂夫的。宝贝，我打电话是想告诉你，我这个周末去不了了，因为他们让我去加班。我没能请到周末的假。我原以为周六能去看你，但我没能做到。
I want to say hi to Bobby Brown in the Wynne unit. My precious son-in-law. I want to urge you to be kind tomorrow, OK? Because Sandy will be coming to see you.
我想问候温恩单位的鲍比·布朗。我亲爱的女婿。我想敦促你明天表现好一点，好吗？因为桑迪明天会去看你。
Hi, John. I hope that your radio's not fading out tonight. Kay and I aren't going to make it this weekend. Bless her little heart, she got her a job. And she just can't hardly go. It just wore her out.
嗨，约翰。希望你今晚的收音机没信号不稳。凯和我这个周末去不了了。保佑她那颗纯真的心，她找到了一份工作。她几乎没法去了。这让她筋疲力尽。
Then another third of the calls are people for whom this is the only communication. People who can't afford, don't have the resources. Even if they made it to Huntsville from Houston, then would have to use a cab, which is $70 or $80, to get from downtown small town Texas out to the prison, and they just don't have the kind of resources to do that.
然后另外三分之一的电话是关于那些视此为唯一沟通渠道的人。那些负担不起、没有资源的人。即使他们从休斯顿赶到了亨茨维尔，他们还得打出租车，那要70或80美元，才能从德克萨斯的小城镇中心赶到监狱，他们根本没有那种资源。
Hi. This is Carol and David, say hello.
嗨。这是卡罗尔和大卫，打个招呼。
Hi.
嗨。
Hi. And we're calling from Mackinaw, Illinois for Joe Paul. Hi, Joe. We love you, and we're doing--
嗨。我们从伊利诺伊州的麦基诺为乔·保罗打的电话。嗨，乔。我们爱你，我们正在——
This is for my son John. I got your letter. I'm glad you got it all off your chest, but right now there's no way I could move back to Houston. I wish I could. But maybe once you get out, then Roseanne and I can.
这是给我的儿子约翰的。我收到你的信了。很高兴你把心里的事都说出来了，但现在我没法搬回休斯顿。我希望我可以。但也许等你出来后，罗珊和我可以。
Yeah, OK. This is Uncle Henry. And Lee Junior, I love you, man. I haven't forgotten you. I haven't forgotten either one of you. And I'll be so glad when you get home, man. Just hang in there, you hear? All right. Merry Christmas.
是的，好的。我是亨利叔叔。还有小李，我爱你，伙计。我没有忘记你。我也没忘记你们俩。当你回家时我会很高兴的，伙计。坚持住，听到了吗？好的。圣诞快乐。
And the remaining third are incidental conversations. People who don't call in regularly. The first 2/3 are people who call in regularly. And usually-- well, not usually. But occasionally they call in in a matter of crisis. You know, like, Johnny, this is your sister Sue, and mama died.
剩下的三分之一是偶发的对话。不经常打进来的那些人。前三分之二是经常打进来的。通常——嗯，不一定。但偶尔他们会在危机时刻打来。你知道，比如，“约翰尼，我是你的妹妹苏，妈妈去世了”。
Does that actually happen a lot, that someone will call to inform someone who is in prison of a loved one who's died?
这种情况真的经常发生吗，有人打电话来通知监狱里的人他们的亲人去世了？
Well, Ira, it is even worse than that. The Prison Show is famous for hearing voices that, over a long period of time, weaken and diminish. The one that comes to mind is Ms. White. Her son was sentenced to a long, long time. And when he first went, she was a regular caller. And then she announced one day that she had had some surgery about some cancer. And that didn't work, and the cancer grew, and her voice grew weaker. Ms. White was with me a couple of years. And then her daughter got on and said she died.
嗯，艾拉，甚至比那更糟。“监狱节目”以听到那些声音而闻名，这些声音在很长一段时间里逐渐变得微弱、消退。我想到的是怀特女士。她的儿子被判了很长很长的刑期。他刚进去的时候，她是常客。然后有一天她宣布她做了癌症手术。没成功，癌症扩散了，她的声音变得越来越虚弱。怀特女士跟我通了两年的电话。然后她的女儿打过来说她去世了。
This is Keith's mother. Keith, I wanted to let you know, yes, we did get your letter today. And I did have laryngitis about two weeks, and I couldn't talk to anybody, so that's why I didn't get to put the call through. And just love you much and miss you.
我是基思的妈妈。基思，我想让你知道，是的，我们今天收到你的信了。我确实得了两周的喉炎，我没法跟任何人说话，所以这就是我没能打电话的原因。只是非常爱你，想念你。
Earl, this is Mama. I love you and merry Christmas, and we'll be together next year. I can't do that.
厄尔，我是妈妈。我爱你，圣诞快乐，我们明年会团聚的。我做不到。
Hi, honey. This is me. It's Theresa. Well, I've kind of sort of got a little bit of bad news. I'm not real sure. But I think I told you in my letter that I was going to spend Thanksgiving with my mom and my stepfather and everybody. Well, I did, and it's not real great. Course, you know, they offered the car, but they also offered the other things I was telling you about. So it's an either or situation. So you know what I'm talking about. At least I hope you know what I'm talking about.
嗨，亲爱的。是我。我是特蕾莎。嗯，我有一点坏消息。我不确定。但我信里可能告诉你了，我要和妈妈、继父还有大家一起过感恩节。嗯，我去了，感觉不太好。当然，你知道，他们提供了车，但他们也提出了我跟你说的其他条件。所以这是一个非此即彼的情况。所以你知道我在说什么。至少我希望你知道我在说什么。
Ray, let me ask you. What is she talking about?
雷，请问一下。她在说什么？
What we have here is the radio prison show equivalent of the Dear John letter. Apparently, reading between the lines of course, Theresa's been calling him several months. And there has been a struggle. Her family does not approve of her relationship. And so over the Thanksgiving dinner, they had come to an understanding, they would give her a car and other things if she would leave him.
我们这里有的是广播监狱节目版的“亲爱的约翰”分手信。显然，读懂字里行间的意思，特蕾莎已经给他打了好几个月电话了。一直有冲突。她的家人不赞同她的关系。所以感恩节晚宴上，他们达成了共识，如果她离开他，他们就给她一辆车和其他东西。
So people will just call up and break up with their boyfriends and husbands over the radio?
所以人们真的会打电话来，在广播里和男朋友、丈夫分手吗？
It's just another form of communication, Ira. This is the way people can communicate. And I get everything. I get "You SOB, you sent me-- I got the letter you intended that other woman." And what we have here is we have a mail officer deciding, this guy's running a sham on these two women. It may be a woman mail officer. So the best way to fix that is just to switch the letters in the envelopes.
这只是另一种交流形式，艾拉。这是人们沟通的方式。我什么都听过。我收到过“你这个浑蛋，你给我寄了——我收到了你写给那个女人的信”。我们这里发生的是，有一个邮政官员决定，这家伙在骗这两个女人。可能是一个女性邮政官员。所以解决这个问题的最好办法就是把信封里的信调换一下。
Has that happened more than once on the show?
这种事在节目里发生过不止一次吗？
Oh, yes. That happens pretty regularly.
噢，是的。这相当经常发生。
Man.
天哪。
Hi Joe, I love you. And we miss you with all of our hearts. And we just are so grateful that you're our brother. We feel like we're the ones that are blessed. I know you say you do in all the letters. But we're the ones that are blessed to have you.
嗨，乔，我爱你。我们全心全意地想你。我们只是非常感激你是我们的兄弟。我们觉得我们才是那个有福气的人。我知道你在所有的信里都这么说。但我们才是那个有福气能拥有你的人。
David at the Wynne unit. Honey, I love you and I miss you, and I'm going to try. I want you to know that I had a very, very bad accident. And I'm going to try to make it down there, because I haven't seen you and I need you to see me. I need you to be strong, because it kind of messed up my left side of my face. And I need to have your strength and your faith to hang in there with me, OK, when I come down there.
温恩单位的大卫。亲爱的，我爱你，我想你，我会努力的。我想让你知道，我发生了一场非常非常严重的事故。我会尽力赶到那里，因为我没见到你，我需要你见到我。我需要你坚强，因为我的脸左侧有点受伤了。我需要你的力量和信仰，在我赶过去的时候和你一起坚持下去，好吗？
Ray, talk about some of the other regular callers who you have.
雷，谈谈你还有哪些其他的常客。
Well, [? Gladewater ?] is this kind of rough Texas-accented older man. He's a very easily identifiable voice that calls in. And he calls his son Sweetheart. And I have actually met Sweetheart. Sweetheart weighs 300 pounds, and he's not all that heavy-set. I mean, we're talking about a seriously large human being.
嗯，［？格莱德沃特？］是一个带有粗犷德克萨斯口音的老男人。他是一个很容易辨认声音的打入者。他管他儿子叫“甜心”。我其实见过“甜心”。“甜心”重达300磅，他并不只是那种虚胖。我的意思是，我们说的是一个体型非常巨大的生物。
Tall.
很高。
Big, big man. Big, brawn, broad-shouldered tall man. He's doing life. He's not going to get out in time for Mama and Daddy to see him. They're going to die before he gets out.
又高又大。高大、宽肩膀、魁梧的男人。他被判了无期徒刑。他没法在父母活着时出来了。父母会在他出来之前就去世。
What do you think it's like for Sweetheart to be called Sweetheart over the radio in a setting where people are pretty mean, and they can hear him being called Sweetheart.
你觉得在监狱那种大家都很刻薄、而且周围人能听到他被叫“甜心”的环境下，被在广播里叫“甜心”对他来说是什么感觉？
Well, at his size, maybe he doesn't have anything to worry about.
嗯，以他的体型，也许他没什么可担心的。
Good point, yeah.
有道理，是的。
He is at a unit that is designated for older inmates.
他所在的单位是专门为老年囚犯设立的。
In a broader sense, in general, I mean, what do you know about what it's like for prisoners to have such intimate things said to them, and then to have it heard by a lot of people in an environment where people are not so open with each other?
从更广泛的意义上讲，我的意思是，你了解囚犯们听到别人对他们说这么私密的话，然后在这样一个人们彼此不够开放的环境下被很多人听到，是什么感觉吗？
Actually, I think that's probably the best thing that happens. You know, what's wrong with prison is that there's no trust in that society. There's no caring in that society. There's no sharing in that society. It's one to a box kind of scared insecurity lifestyle. And I think that Sweetheart and things like that breaks that down. I think it's very healthy for inmates to come out of different cell blocks, and get in line in the chow hall, and somebody say, I heard your mama last night, and she sounded like she's getting better. Or I heard your daddy call you Sweetheart.
其实，我认为这可能是发生过的最好的事情。你知道，监狱的问题在于那个社会里没有信任。那个社会里没有关心。那个社会里没有分享。那是一种关在盒子里、担惊受怕的不安全生活方式。我认为“甜心”之类的事情打破了这种隔阂。我认为囚犯们从不同的牢房出来，在食堂排队，有人说“我昨晚听到你妈妈的声音了，听起来她好转了”或者“我听到你爸爸叫你甜心”，这对他们非常健康。
Ray Hill, host of the prison show, heard every Friday night on KPFT in Houston.
雷·希尔，监狱节目的主持人，每周五晚在休斯顿的KPFT播出。
In thinking about what song to put after his story, we decided to turn back to Ed Ryder, the jazz musician we heard from at the beginning of today's program. It's a song that Ed used to listen to all the time back when he was still locked up.
在思考他的故事后放什么歌时，我们决定回到埃德·莱德身边，就是我们在节目开头听到的那位爵士乐手。这首歌是埃德在被关押期间一直听的歌。
When I was in Graterford, I always listened to it. I had a tape of it. "God Bless the Child Who's Got His Own" by Billie Holliday. And what it meant to me when I was at Graterford-- when she said, "Them that's got shall get, them that's not shall lose, so the Bible says, and it still is news. Mama may have, papa may have, but God bless the child that has his own."
当我在格雷特福德时，我总是听它。我有一盘磁带。比莉·哈乐黛的《上帝保佑有主见的孩子》。当我在格雷特福德时，它对我的意义是——当她说，“拥有者将会得到，一无所有者将会失去，圣经上这么说，而且依然是新闻。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但上帝保佑有主见的孩子。”
Well, in my mind, at Graterford, I thought that yes, I was the child that had his own. Because I was out here on my own. I had no help at the time. There was no hope. I seen no way. I was like a child. I was like a child, because I had no one I could turn to. My parents had passed. I had no one I could turn to. And I felt like, every time I would listen to that, I felt as though she was talking directly to me.
嗯，在我心里，在格雷特福德，我想是的，我就是那个有主见的孩子。因为我独自在这里。当时我没得到任何帮助。没有任何希望。我看不到出路。我就像个孩子。我就像个孩子，因为我没有任何人可以求助。我的父母已经去世了。我没有任何人可以依靠。每次听这首歌时，我感觉她就像在直接跟我对话。
So you guys want to hear it without any music? Without a guitar or keyboard, or--? Let me see. All right. Here you go.
那么你们想听没有伴奏的版本吗？没有吉他或键盘，或者——？让我看看。好吧。给你们唱。
Them that's got shall get. Them that's not will lose. So the Bible said. And it still is news. Mama may have. Papa may have. But God bless the child that's got his own, that's got his own.
拥有者将会得到。一无所有者将会失去。圣经上是这么说的。而且依然是新闻。妈妈可能有。爸爸可能有。但上帝保佑有主见的孩子，那个有主见的孩子。
That's basically some of it. A little cold, but that's basically it, I guess.
基本就是这样了。有点冷清，但这就是大概的内容，我想。
Act Two, Mother's Day.
第二幕，“母亲节”。
As the prison population rises, the proportion of female inmates has also been on the rise. Women now make up 6% of the nation's prison community. And on Mother's Day, visiting rooms are packed as relatives bring the children to these women. Amanda Coyne just made the trip with her nephew to see her sister, Jennifer.
随着监狱人口增加，女性囚犯的比例也在上升。女性现在占全国监狱社区的6%。在母亲节，探视室挤满了亲戚，他们把孩子带给这些女性。阿曼达·科恩刚和她的侄子一起去看了她的姐姐詹妮弗。
You can spot the convict moms here in the visiting room by the way they hold and touch their children and by the single flower that is perched in front of them. A rose, a tulip, a daffodil. Occasionally, a mother will pick up her present and bring it to her nose when one of the bearers of the single flower, her child, asks if she likes it. And the mother will respond the way the mothers always have and always will respond when presented with a gift on this day. "Oh, I just love it. It's perfect. I'll put it in my Bible." Or "I'll put it on my desk, right next to your school picture." And always, "It's the best one here."
你可以在探视室里通过她们拥抱和抚摸孩子的方式，以及她们面前摆着的那支花，认出那些被关押的妈妈们。一朵玫瑰、郁金香、水仙花。偶尔，一位母亲会拿起礼物，当拿花的孩子问她喜不喜欢时，她会把礼物凑到鼻尖。母亲们会像以前以及永远会做的那样做出回应：“哦，我太喜欢了。太完美了。我会把它放在圣经里。”或者“我会把它放在我的书桌上，就在你的学校照片旁边。”而且总是，“这是这里最好的一朵。”
But most of what is being smelled today is the children themselves. While the other adults are plunking coins into the vending machine, the mothers take deep whiffs from the back of their children's necks, or kiss and smell the backs of their knees, or take off their shoes and tickle their feet, and then pull them close to their noses. They hold them tight and take in their own second scent, the scent assuring them that these are still their children, and that they still belong to them.
但今天闻得最多的还是孩子们本身。当其他大人们往自动售货机里投硬币时，母亲们会深吸孩子们脖子后面的味道，或者亲吻并闻闻孩子膝盖后的味道，或者脱掉他们的鞋子挠挠他们的脚，然后把他们紧紧贴在鼻子上。她们紧紧抱着他们，吸入属于她们的第二种气味，那种气味向她们保证这些依然是她们的孩子，她们依然拥有他们。
The visitors are allowed to bring in pockets full of coins, and today, that Mother's Day flower. And I know from previous visits to my older sister here at the Federal Prison Camp for Women in Pekin, Illinois, there's always an aberrant urge to gather immediately around the vending machines. The sandwiches are stale, the coffee week, the candy bars the ones we always pass up in a convenience store. But after we hand the children over to their mothers, we gravitate towards those machines. Like milling in the kitchen at a party, we all do it, and nobody knows why.
探视者被允许带进满口袋的硬币，以及今天的母亲节花朵。从我之前去伊利诺伊州佩金的联邦女子监狱探望我大姐的经历来看，总有一种异常的冲动，让人立刻聚在自动售货机旁。三明治变质了，咖啡寡淡，糖果条是我们平时在便利店里看都不看一眼的那种。但在我们把孩子交还给他们的母亲后，我们还是会被那些机器吸引。就像聚会上大家磨蹭在厨房里一样，我们都这么做了，没人知道为什么。
While my sister Jennifer is with her son in the playroom, an inmate's mother comes over to introduce herself to my younger sister Charity, my brother John, and me. She tells us about visiting her daughter in a higher security prison before she was transferred here. The woman looks old and tired, and her shoulders sag under the weight of her recently acquired bitterness. "Pit of fire," she says, shaking her head. "Like a pit of fire straight from hell. Never seen anything like it. Like something out of an old movie about prisons." Her voice is getting louder, and she looks at each of us with pleading eyes. "My daughter was in there. Don't even get me started on that place. "Women die there." John and Charity and I silently exchanged glances.
当我的姐姐詹妮弗和她的儿子在游戏室时，一位囚犯的母亲过来向我妹妹查丽蒂、哥哥约翰和我介绍自己。她告诉我们在她女儿被转到这里之前，去更高安全级别的监狱探视她的经历。这位妇女看起来苍老而疲惫，肩膀在刚获得的苦涩重压下塌陷。“火坑，”她摇着头说。“简直就是地狱里的火坑。从未见过那样的东西。就像关于监狱的老电影里的场景。”她的声音越来越大，用恳求的眼神看着我们每一个人。“我女儿就在里面。别提那个地方了。女人们死在那里。”约翰、查丽蒂和我默默地交换了眼神。
"My daughter would come to the visiting room with a black eye, and I'd think, all she did was sit in the car while her boyfriend ran into the house. She didn't even touch the stuff. Never even handled it." She continues to stare at us each in turn. "Ten years. That boyfriend talked, and he got three years. She didn't know anything. Had nothing to tell them. They gave her 10 years. They call it conspiracy. Conspiracy? Aren't there real criminals out there?" She asks this with hands outstretched, waiting for an answer that none of us can give her.
“我女儿来探视室时带着黑眼圈，我想，她只是在男友跑进屋里时坐在车里等而已。她甚至没碰过那些东西。从来没接触过。”她继续盯着我们每一个人。“十年。那个男友坦白了，他只判了三年。她什么都不知道。她没有什么可告诉他们的。他们判了她10年。他们称之为共谋。共谋？外面没有真正的罪犯了吗？”她摊开双手问这个问题，等待着我们任何人都无法给出的答案。
The woman's daughter, the conspirator, is chasing her son through the maze of chairs and tables and through the other children. She's a 24 year old blond whom I'll call Stephanie, with Dorothy Hamill hair and matching dimples. She looks like any girl you might see in a shopping mall in middle America. She catches her chocolate-brown son and tickles him, and they laugh and trip and fall together onto the floor, and they laugh harder.
那个所谓的共谋者，也就是那个女人的女儿，正在椅子和桌子的迷宫中以及其他孩子中间追逐着她的儿子。她是一个24岁的金发女郎，我姑且叫她斯蒂芬妮，有着多萝西·哈米尔式的发型和配套的酒窝。她看起来就像你在美国中部的任何购物中心里看到的女孩一样。她抓住了她那巧克力棕色的儿子并挠他痒痒，他们笑着、跌倒在一起，又笑得更开心了。
She has done the tour, and her son is a well-traveled six year old. He has spent weekends visiting his mother in prisons in Kentucky, Texas, Connecticut, the pit of fire. And now at last here, the camp, minimum security, Pekin, Illinois. [? Eli ?] looks older than his age, but his shoulders do not droop like his grandmother's. On the contrary, his bitterness lifts them and his chin higher than a child's should be, and the childlike wide-eyed curiosity has been replaced by defiance.
她已经经历过转监，而她的儿子是一个“周游列国”的六岁小孩。他度过了很多个周末，在肯塔基州、德克萨斯州、康涅狄格州的监狱——那个火坑——探望他的母亲。现在终于到了这里，低安全级别的佩金营地，伊利诺伊州。［？伊莱？］看起来比他的年龄更成熟，但他的肩膀并没有像他祖母那样下垂。相反，他的苦涩使它们和他的下巴抬得比孩子应该有的位置更高，童年时那种睁大眼睛的好奇心已经被叛逆所取代。
You can see his emerging hostility as he and his mother play together. She tells him to pick up the toy that he threw, say, or to put the deck of cards away. His face turns sullen, but she persists. She takes him by the shoulders and looks him in the eye, and he uses one of his hands to swat at her. She grabs the hand, and he swats with the other. Eventually, she pulls him towards her, and smells the top of his head, and she picks up the cards or the toy herself. After all, it is Mother's Day, and she sees him so rarely. But her acquiescence makes him angrier, and he stalks out of the playroom with his shoulders thrown back.
你可以看到当他和母亲一起玩时，他那种显露出来的敌意。比如她说让他捡起他扔掉的玩具，或者把纸牌收起来。他的脸变得阴沉，但她坚持要求。她抓住他的肩膀注视他的眼睛，而他用一只手去拍打她。她抓住那只手，他又用另一只手拍打。最终，她把他拉向自己，闻了闻他的头顶，自己捡起了牌或玩具。毕竟，今天是母亲节，她很少见到他。但她的顺从使他更生气，他耸着肩膀走出了游戏室。
Toby, my brother and sister and I assure one another, will not have these resentments. He is better taken care of than most. He is living with relatives in Wisconsin. Good, solid, middle class, church-going relatives. And when he visits us, his aunts and uncle, we take him out for adventures where we we walk down the alley of a city and pretend that we are being chased by the bad guys. We buy him fast food, and his uncle John keeps him up well past his bedtime, enthralling him with the stories of the monkeys he met in India.
托比，我的哥哥和姐姐向我保证，不会有这些怨恨。他比大多数孩子都照顾得好。他住在威斯康星州的亲戚家里。好心、踏实、中产阶级、信奉宗教的亲戚。而当我们去探望我们，也就是他的阿姨和舅舅时，我们会带他去冒险，在大城市的胡同里走，假装我们正在被坏人追赶。我们给他买快餐，舅舅约翰让他过了睡觉时间还不睡，用他在印度遇到猴子的故事让他着迷。
A perfect mix, we try to convince but another. Until we take him to see his mother, and on the drive back, he asks the question that most confuses him, and no doubt, all the other children who spend much of their lives in prison visiting rooms. "Is my mommy a bad guy?" It's a question that most seriously disorders his five year old need to clearly separate right from wrong. And because our need is perhaps just as great, it is the question that haunts us, as well.
这是一个完美的结合，我们试图向彼此证明。直到我们带他去看他的母亲，而在回来的路上，他问出了那个让他最困惑的问题，毫无疑问，这也是所有把大部分时间花在监狱探视室的孩子们都会问的问题：“我的妈妈是坏人吗？”这是一个最严重地扰乱了他作为一个五岁孩子清晰区分是非需求的问题。而因为我们的需求可能同样巨大，这也是困扰我们的问题。
Now, however, the answer is relatively simple. In a few years, it won't be. In a few years, we'll have to explain mandatory minimums, and the war on drugs, and the murky conspiracy laws, and the enormous amount of money and time the federal agents pump into imprisoning low-level drug dealers and those who happen to be their friends and their lovers. In a few years, he will have the reasoning skills to ask why so many armed robbers, and rapists, and child molesters, and, indeed, murderers, are punished less severely than his mother. When he's older, we will somehow have to explain to him the difference between federal crimes, which don't allow for parole, and state crimes, which do. We will have to explain that his mother was taken from him for five years not because she was a drug dealer, but because she made four phone calls for someone she loved.
然而现在，答案相对简单。再过几年，就不会简单了。再过几年，我们就必须向他解释强制最低刑期、毒品战争、模糊的共谋法，以及联邦特工投入巨额金钱和时间将底层毒贩以及那些碰巧是他们朋友和爱人的人关进监狱的事实。再过几年，他将拥有提问的思维能力：为什么这么多持械抢劫犯、强奸犯、猥亵儿童者，甚至是杀人犯，受到的惩罚却比他的母亲轻？当他长大后，我们必须以某种方式向他解释联邦罪行（不允许假释）和州罪行（允许假释）之间的区别。我们必须向他解释，他的母亲被从他身边带走五年不是因为她是毒贩，而是因为她为她所爱的人打了四个电话。
But we also know it is vitally important that we explain all this without betraying our bitterness. We understand the danger of abstract anger, of being disillusioned with your country. And most of all, we do not want him to inherit that legacy. We would still like him to be raised as we were, with the idea that we live in the best country in the world, with the best legal system in the world, a legal system carefully designed to be immune to political mood swings and public hysteria. A system that promises to fit the punishment to the crime. We want him to be a good citizen. We want him to have absolute faith that he lives in a fair country, a country that watches over and protects its most vulnerable citizens, its women and its children.
但我们也知道，在不背叛我们苦涩感的情况下解释清楚这一切至关重要。我们理解抽象愤怒的危险，理解对国家幻灭的危险。最重要的是，我们不希望他继承那份遗产。我们仍然希望他像我们小时候一样长大，带着我们生活在世界上最好的国家、拥有世界上最好的法律体系的观念，这是一个精心设计、旨在不受政治情绪波动和公众歇斯底里影响的法律体系。一个承诺让惩罚与罪行相匹配的体系。我们希望他成为一个好公民。我们希望他对生活在一个公平的国家有绝对的信心，一个关注并保护其最脆弱公民（妇女和儿童）的国家。
So for now, we simply say, "Toby, your mother isn't bad. She just did a bad thing. Like when you put rocks in the lawn mower's gas tank. You weren't bad then. You just did a bad thing." Once, after being given this weak explanation, he said, "I wish I could have done something really bad like my mommy, so I could go to prison, too, and be with her."
所以现在，我们只是说：“托比，你的妈妈不是坏人。她只是做了一件坏事。就像你把石头放进割草机的油箱里一样。那时候你并不是个坏孩子。你只是做了一件坏事。”有一次，在他得到这个苍白的解释后，他说：“我希望我能做一件真正坏的事，像我妈妈那样，这样我也能进监狱，和她在一起。”
It's now 3 o'clock. Visiting ends at 3:30. The fathers, mothers, sisters, brothers, and the few boyfriends, and the very few husbands, are beginning to show signs of gathering the trash. The mothers of the infants are giving their heads one last whiff before tucking them and their paraphernalia into their respective carrying cases. The visitors meander towards the door, leaving the older children with their mothers for one last word.
现在是下午3点。探视时间3:30结束。父亲们、母亲们、姐妹们、兄弟们，以及少数男朋友和极少数丈夫，开始显露出收集垃圾的迹象。婴儿的母亲们在把孩子和他们的随身物品塞进各自的提包前，最后一次闻了闻他们的头顶。探视者漫步走向门口，留下较大的孩子与他们的母亲进行最后几句话的告别。
But the mothers never say what they want to say to their children. They say things like, "Do well in school. Be nice to your sister. Be good for Aunt Betty or Grandma." They don't say, "I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry. I love you more than anything else in the world, and I think about you every minute, and I worry about you with a pain that shoots straight to my heart, a pain so great, I think I'll just burst when I think of you alone without me. I'm sorry."
但母亲们从来没有对孩子说出她们想说的话。她们说的是：“在学校要好好表现。对姐姐好点。要听贝蒂阿姨或奶奶的话。”她们没有说：“对不起，对不起，对不起。我爱你胜过世界上的一切，我每时每刻都在想你，我担心你，这种痛苦直刺我的心脏，如此巨大，以至于每当我想到你孤单一个人，我就觉得心都要碎了。对不起。”
We are standing in front of the double glass doors that lead to the outside world. My older sister holds her son, rocking him gently. They are both crying. We give her a look, and she puts him down. Charity and I grasp each of the small hands, and the four of us walk through the doors. I turn back, and I see a line of women standing behind a glass wall. Some of them are crying, but many simply stare with dazed eyes.
我们站在通往外部世界的双层玻璃门前。我的大姐抱着她的儿子，轻轻地摇晃着。他们都在哭。我们给了她一个眼神，她把他放了下来。查丽蒂和我分别抓住他的一只小手，我们四个人穿过了大门。我回头望去，看见一排妇女站在玻璃墙后。有些人在哭，但许多人只是用茫然的眼睛盯着前方。
Stephanie is holding both of her son's hands in hers and speaking urgently to him. He is struggling and his head is twisting violently back and forth. He frees one of his hands from her grasp, balls up his fist, and punches her in the face. Then he walks with purpose through the glass doors and out the exit.
斯蒂芬妮紧握着她儿子的双手，焦急地对他说着什么。他在挣扎，头猛烈地来回扭动。他从她手中挣脱了一只手，握成拳头，打在她的脸上。然后他坚定地穿过玻璃门，走出了出口。
I look back at her. She is still in a crouched position. She stares, unblinking, through those doors.
我回头看向她。她仍然蹲在那里。她盯着那些大门，没有眨眼。
Amanda Coyne is a graduate student in nonfiction writing at the University of Iowa. This was excerpted from a longer story that originally appeared in Harper's Magazine. 80% of the women in prisons today have children back home. Most of these women are single mothers.
阿曼达·科恩是爱荷华大学非虚构写作的研究生。这是从《哈珀杂志》原载的一篇长文中节选的。今天在监狱里的妇女中有80%在家有孩子。大多数这些妇女是单身母亲。
Coming up. What happens when you mix three well-meaning standup comedians with 800 angry, violent offenders in a maximum security prison two days before Christmas? That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
即将播出：当你把三个满怀好意的脱口秀喜剧演员和800名愤怒的暴力罪犯关进一个最高安全级别的监狱，就在圣诞节前两天，会发生什么？一分钟后继续，来自国际公共广播电台，敬请收听。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and reporters and radio producers to tackle that theme. Today's show, about the tens of millions of people whose own lives are tangled up with our nation's prisons in this period when we have rising rates of incarceration and falling crime rates.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、记者和广播制作人来探讨这个主题。今天的节目是关于数千万人的生活，他们的生活与我国监狱纠缠在一起，在这个我们监禁率上升、犯罪率下降的时期。
In the first half of our show, we've heard mostly about family members of prisoners. In the second half, the half we turn to now, we turn to a few aspects of life for people behind bars in America. We begin with this item. It is Act Three of our program.
在节目的上半部分，我们主要听到了关于囚犯家人的故事。在下半部分，也就是我们现在转向的部分，我们转向美国高墙内人们生活的一些方面。我们从这个项目开始。这是我们节目的第三幕。
Act Three, Who's Your Daddy? This is an excerpt from a pamphlet written by an ex-convict, Stephen Donaldson. A guide for straight men who find themselves entering prison. A warning before we start. This reading contains material that may not be appropriate for some younger listeners. There is no explicit language or graphic depictions of anything, but it does acknowledge the existence of certain sex acts.
第三幕，“谁是你爸爸？”这是前囚犯斯蒂芬·唐纳森写的一本小册子的节选。这是一份为发现自己进入监狱的异性恋男性提供的指南。在开始之前请注意。这段阅读内容可能不适合一些年轻听众。没有明确的语言或对任何事物的图形化描写，但它确实承认了某些性行为的存在。
Many prisoners who have been raped by fellow inmates, or who have been threatened with rape, decide to become hooked up with another prisoner. However distasteful the idea may seem, they believe it to be the least damaging way to survive in custody. In most arrangements, the junior partner-- in prison slang, the catcher or punk-- gives up his independence and his control over his body to a senior partner-- the jocker, man, pitcher, or daddy-- in exchange for protection from violence and sexual assaults by other prisoners. This arrangement, it must be said, is never totally voluntary for the punk. But it is preferable to a series of violent gang rapes, and, in the age of AIDS, far safer.
许多被狱友强奸或被威胁强奸的囚犯决定与另一名囚犯“挂钩”。无论这个想法看起来多么令人反感，他们都认为这是在羁押期间生存的最不具破坏性的方式。在大多数安排中，初级合伙人——在监狱俚语中是“接球手”或“朋克”——为了换取免受其他囚犯暴力和性侵犯的保护，放弃了他们的独立和对自己身体的控制权，转给了一位高级合伙人——“jocker”、“男人”、“投手”或“爸爸”。必须说，对于“朋克”来说，这种安排从来不是完全自愿的。但这比一系列暴力的团伙强奸要好，而且在艾滋病时代，安全得多。
If you want to be able to choose your daddy, tell the other prisoners that you want to hook up. The word will get around fast, and guys will start to talk to you about it. This has to be done quickly. Otherwise, events will overwhelm you, and you may get gang raped or forced to hook up before you can make a choice. Spend as much time as you can with the jockers who want to hook up with you. Ask them lots of questions, and judge for yourself how sincere they are. Ask other prisoners, especially punks and queens, about their reps. The more information you can get, the better your choice will be. Once you make your decision, you are pretty much stuck with it.
如果你想选择你的“爸爸”，告诉其他囚犯你想“挂钩”。消息会传得很快，家伙们会开始和你讨论这件事。这必须尽快完成。否则，事态会压倒你，你可能会在做出选择之前就被团伙强奸或被迫“挂钩”。尽可能多地与想和你“挂钩”的“jocker”相处。问他们很多问题，并自己判断他们有多真诚。向其他囚犯，特别是“朋克”和“女王”，询问他们的口碑。你得到的信息越多，你的选择就会越好。一旦你做出了决定，你就基本被它困住了。
Check out how serious the guy is. Discuss what he expects from you in detail, and try to work out the most favorable agreement. Even put it in writing. Protective pairing is a very serious matter for him, too, since it obligates him to put his life on the line to keep you from harm. Ask him about any previous catchers he's had, how they managed together, and why they split. If any of them are still around, talk with them. Ask jockers how they treat their women, because most jockers treat their punks the same way. If they form real partnerships with their women, they are more likely to do the same with you.
观察那个家伙有多认真。详细讨论他对你的期望，并尝试制定最有利的协议。甚至把它写下来。保护性伴侣对他来说也是一件非常严肃的事情，因为它要求他冒着生命危险让你免受伤害。问他关于他以前的“接球手”、他们相处得如何以及为什么分开的问题。如果他们中的任何一个人还在附近，和他们谈谈。问问“jocker”他们如何对待他们的女人，因为大多数“jocker”对待他们的“朋克”的方式是一样的。如果他们与他们的女人形成真正的伴侣关系，他们更有可能与你这样做。
Jockers may well insist on having sex with you before putting a claim on you. This is not an unreasonable demand, since sex is such an important part of the deal. You can tell a lot about a jock by how he behaves with you sexually. If he shows affection, such as stroking your body or hair, it is a good indication that he wants to treat you like a human being.
“jocker”很可能会坚持在宣称拥有你之前与你发生性关系。这不是一个无理的要求，因为性是这笔交易的重要组成部分。你可以从一个“jocker”在性方面对待你的方式看出很多。如果他表现出深情，比如抚摸你的身体或头发，这是一个很好的迹象，表明他想把你当作一个人来对待。
As soon as it becomes known that you are hooked up-- and the news will spread like wildfire-- everyone will stop hassling you and will deal with you only through your man. Hooking up means you have definitely become a punk, and will be considered a punk for as long as you stay in the joint. So if you decide to hook up, you might as well get used to that status.
一旦你知道你被“挂钩”了——消息会像野火一样蔓延——每个人都会停止骚扰你，只会通过你的“男人”和你打交道。“挂钩”意味着你已经彻底成为了一个“朋克”，只要你呆在里面，就会被视为一个“朋克”。所以如果你决定“挂钩”，你最好还是习惯那种身份。
A jocker frequently loans out his punk to his friends, usually a way of ensuring their loyalty to him or to reinforce his position as a leader. In a way, this is good for you, since the more backup he has, the safer you'll be. And when he's not around, you can turn to his friends in an emergency.
“jocker”经常把他“朋克”借给他的朋友，通常是为了确保他们对他的忠诚或巩固他作为领导者的地位。从某种意义上说，这对你有好处，因为他的支持者越多，你就越安全。当他不在附近时，你可以在紧急情况下求助于他的朋友。
Once the two of you decide to be hooked up, you may well be given duties other than sex. For example, doing his laundry, cleaning his cell, making up his bunk, fixing coffee for him, and giving him back rubs. Although the arrangement is firm-- the pitcher makes the rules and the catcher follows them-- the relationship will usually allow you some room to maneuver and have your wishes considered, as long as you respect the basic rules. While a jocker will never tolerate open rebellion, he usually seeks to get along with this punk and to avoid an atmosphere of constant tension. He would rather relax around his punk, and over time he can and often does develop genuine affection for him. This allows a considerable degree of give and take in the non-sexual aspects of the partnership. But the sexual part is pretty fixed, and you can't really hope to get out of it.
一旦你们两人决定“挂钩”，你很可能会被分配除性以外的职责。例如，洗他的衣服、打扫他的牢房、整理他的床位、为他烧咖啡以及给他按摩背部。尽管这种安排很坚定——“投手”制定规则，“接球手”遵守规则——但只要你尊重基本规则，这种关系通常会给你一些回旋余地并考虑你的意愿。虽然“jocker”绝不会容忍公开叛乱，但他通常寻求与这个“朋克”相处，避免持续紧张的气氛。他宁愿在“朋克”身边放松，随着时间的推移，他可以也经常会对他产生真正的感情。这允许伴侣关系中非性方面的相当程度的妥协。但性方面的部分是相当固定的，你不能指望摆脱它。
You have to understand that for jockers, the world of confinement is one of constant competition, with everyone looking for a weakness, so guys put up a false front which never admits any vulnerability. This makes them less human. When they get hooked up, they have someone to relate to. They can feel you're on the same team. They can relax as they learn to trust you. They may even show an entirely different and unexpected side of themselves, sharing their own anxieties, fears, and deepest feelings. In turn, they will listen to you as you learn to trust them and talk about your own feelings. Thus, you stand a good chance of developing a human relationship in which each of you really cares about the other and works to keep the relationship smooth.
你必须明白，对于“jocker”来说，禁闭的世界是一个持续竞争的世界，每个人都在寻找弱点，所以家伙们摆出一副从不承认任何脆弱的虚假面孔。这使他们不那么人性化。当他们“挂钩”时，他们有可以交流的对象。他们能感觉到你在同一个团队。他们能学着信任你，从而放松下来。他们甚至可能展现出完全不同和意想不到的一面，分享他们自己的焦虑、恐惧和内心深处的感受。反过来，当你学着信任他们并谈论你自己的感受时，他们也会倾听你。因此，你们很有可能发展出一种彼此真正关心并努力保持关系顺畅的人际关系。
Human beings are remarkably adaptable creatures. It is true that if you become a punk and are locked up for a long time, you will get somewhat used to the punk role. This varies a lot from one punk to another. Some still hate every sex act after a decade of doing it every day. Others focus on the other aspects of the relationship and find some value there. Some treasure the security it brings.
人类是极其适应的生物。诚然，如果你成为一名“朋克”并被关押很长时间，你会慢慢适应“朋克”的角色。这在不同的“朋克”之间差异很大。有些人即使每天做这种事十年后，仍然讨厌每一次性行为。另一些人关注这种关系的其他方面并从中找到某种价值。有些人珍惜它带来的安全感。
Many punks who have good relationships actually become fond of their jockers. It is not so uncommon in the unusual conditions of confinement for two straight guys to fall in love with each other over time. Psychologists generally consider adaptation to be a healthy reaction to a situation that you can not change. So don't worry about it if you find yourself adapting to the role. Once you're out, you can reverse the process and work on reclaiming the full expression of your masculine identity.
许多拥有良好关系的“朋克”实际上对他们的“jocker”产生了感情。在禁闭的非正常条件下，两个异性恋男人随着时间的推移爱上彼此并不罕见。心理学家通常认为适应是一种对无法改变的情况的健康反应。所以如果你发现自己适应了这个角色，不必担心。一旦你出去了，你就可以扭转这个过程，努力恢复你男性身份的充分表达。
Unfortunately, many, if not most jockers, will try to get their punks to be as feminine in appearance and behavior as possible, because they are more comfortable pretending that they are relating sexually to some kind of female than to another male. But they also know that you're a punk, not a queen, and that such things don't come naturally to you. You should ask about such things before accepting a claim, and make it clear that retaining your masculine identity is important to you.
不幸的是，许多，如果不是大多数“jocker”，会试图让他们的“朋克”在外表和行为上尽可能女性化，因为他们更舒服地假装他们是在和某种女性进行性关系，而不是另一个男性。但他们也知道你是“朋克”，不是“女王”，这种事情对你来说并不自然。你应该在接受宣称之前询问这些事情，并明确表示保持你的男性身份对你很重要。
Some jockers don't care. I was hooked up once with a guy who let me grow a mustache. Most will still refer to you as him and use your male name. Others may insist that you shave your legs, grow long hair, and use a feminine nickname. No matter what you have to do, remember that it is all an act, and that you can go back to your normal behavior as soon as you get out.
有些“jocker”不在乎。我曾经和一个让我留胡子的家伙“挂钩”。大多数人仍然会称呼你为“他”并使用你的男性名字。其他人可能会坚持让你刮腿毛、留长发并使用女性化的昵称。无论你必须做什么，记住这一切都只是表演，一旦你出去了，你就可以回到你的正常行为。
That's a lot of advice, but you'll need it. Good luck finding a decent man. And remember that you will leave it all behind, except for a much better understanding of men and of women, when you walk out the front gate.
这有很多建议，但你会需要的。祝你找到一个体面的男人。记住，当你走出前门时，你会把这一切抛在身后，除了对男人和女人有更好的理解。
Chicago actor Larry DiStasi read from the pamphlet Hooking Up: Protective Pairing For Punks. The pamphlet was written by Stephen Donaldson, who died in 1996 of complications from an HIV infection he received when he was gang raped in prison.
芝加哥演员拉里·迪斯塔西阅读了《挂钩：为朋克准备的保护性伴侣》手册。该手册由斯蒂芬·唐纳森编写，他于1996年死于他在监狱中被团伙强奸时感染的艾滋病毒并发症。
Act Four. Rick Reynolds is a guy who does these amazingly honest and very funny monologues onstage. And he tells this story about visiting a maximum security prison in Vacaville, California. Rick Reynolds is somebody who has a compulsion to say the exact thing that you're not supposed to say in any given situation. In this case, he was invited to perform at the facility's Christmas party. Again, a warning. Although this is mild, some content may not be suitable for younger listeners.
第四幕。瑞克·雷诺兹是一个在舞台上做这些极其诚实和非常搞笑的独白的家伙。他讲述了这个关于访问加利福尼亚州瓦卡维尔最高安全级别监狱的故事。瑞克·雷诺兹是一个有强迫症的人，总是在任何特定情况下说出绝对不该说的话。在这种情况下，他被邀请在设施的圣诞派对上表演。再次提醒。虽然这很温和，但有些内容可能不适合年轻听众。
I remember driving up to this thing, not knowing what to expect. December 23. A good friend of mine, David Feldman, sitting next to me, going to be the middle act, and Jose Simon in the backseat. We get to this place, and we're frisked, and the metal detectors, and you're led down these long corridors, and it smells of a hospital. And you feel like a little kid in grade school going back to your school at night, and you're not supposed to be there somehow.
我记得开车去的时候，不知道会发生什么。12月23日。我的一个好朋友大卫·费尔德曼坐在我旁边，将担任中间人，而何塞·西蒙坐在后座。我们到了那个地方，被搜身，穿过金属探测器，被带下长长的走廊，空气中弥漫着医院的味道。你感觉就像一个回校上夜课的小学生，不知怎么的你不应该在那里。
And eventually we're led into this big gymnasium. Like your high school gym. Four sets of bleachers pulled out, little stage in front of it. Bleachers packed with about 800 pissed off guys in blue denim. As soon as they see us, it is like a scene from a bad prison movie. They started whistling and catcalling and yelling, "Bend over. Whoo. Fresh meat." Apparently it was mating season in the prison. And I'm scared.
最终我们被带进了这个大体育馆。就像你的高中体育馆一样。四组看台拉开了，前面有一个小舞台。看台上挤满了大约800个穿着蓝色牛仔服的愤怒家伙。他们一看到我们，就像一部糟糕的监狱电影里的场景。他们开始吹口哨、喝倒彩并大喊：“弯下腰。噢。新鲜肉。”显然这是监狱里的发情期。我害怕了。
We're led into this little room. and this big, pompous, stocky guard starts laying down all of the prison rules. "You're not to mention homosexuality within the prison community. You're not to mention drug usage within the present community. You're not to mention black and white relations within the prison community. We have had riots at this facility." Then he got very serious and said, "If any inmate crosses the yellow line in front of the stage, you immediately turn and run for the double doors in the back of the room. But don't worry. We got snipers in the perch."
我们被带进一个小房间。一个大而自负、身材粗壮的警卫开始制定所有的监狱规则。“你们不能提及监狱社区内的同性恋。你们不能提及监狱社区内的毒品使用。你们不能提及监狱社区内的黑白关系。这个设施发生过暴动。”然后他变得非常严肃并说：“如果任何囚犯越过舞台前的黄线，你们立即转身跑向房间后面的双开门。但别担心。我们在岗哨里有狙击手。”
Oh, well, suddenly I'm at ease. You hear that, Dave? Snipers in the perch. Nothing to worry about now. What he's talking about, of course, guards with guns up in these towers. And I don't know about you, but nothing says Christmas to me more than guards with guns.
哦，好吧，我突然放松了。你听到了吗，戴夫？岗哨里的狙击手。现在没什么好担心的了。当然，他指的是在这些塔楼上有枪的警卫。我不知道你们怎么想，但对我来说，没有什么比拿枪的警卫更能体现圣诞节了。
Also, we weren't supposed to mention the guards or the guns or the towers. Basically, we weren't supposed to talk about anything, especially not about K block, which I didn't even know existed before they brought it up. This is where they kept their incorrigibles. This was the cream of the crop out here.
此外，我们不应该提及警卫或枪支或塔楼。基本上，我们不应该谈论任何事情，尤其不能谈论K区，在他们提起之前我甚至不知道它的存在。这是他们关押“不可救药者”的地方。这是这里的精英。
Well, this nightmare gig begins with them announcing "Your host and MC, Jose Simon." Jose runs out. Takes the mike. A nightmare. Just a nightmare. I can not overstate how horrendous this situation is. 800 guys, not one of them listening. They're all screaming at the top of their lungs. "[BLEEP] you! Eat [BLEEP]! Bend over!" It's just awful. I mean, it's just awful.
好吧，这场噩梦般的演出开始了，他们宣布：“你们的主持人和司仪，何塞·西蒙。”何塞跑了出去。拿起了麦克风。噩梦。简直是噩梦。我无法夸大这种情况是多么的可怕。800个家伙，没一个人听。他们都在竭尽全力尖叫。“［被哔］你！吃［被哔］！弯下腰！”真是太糟糕了。我的意思是，真是太糟糕了。
And I'm watching from the side, thinking, it's going to stop. They're going to stop this. Nobody stopped it.  Nobody tried to stop it. It's one of those life situations-- and hopefully you can relate to this. I'm supposed to be paid $500, right? I would have gladly said, you keep the $500. Here's $2,000 more. Let me go home. In two and a half hours, I'm with my wife. Please.
我从旁边看着，心想，它会停下来的。他们会停止这一切的。没有人停止。没人试图停止。这是生活中的情况之一——希望你能感同身受。我本应得到500美元，对吧？我会很乐意地说，这500美元你留着吧。这是2000美元，再多给点。让我回家。两个半小时后，我就能见到我的妻子了。求求你们。
Nobody in the room is laughing except Feldman and I, watching from the side. Nothing funnier then another comic eating it onstage, really. Jose comes off, drenched in sweat. Feldman goes out, tries to do political material. Come on, these guys don't vote. They've been in prison their whole lives. I have never laughed harder in my life. No never. I'm just busting a gut, watching Feldman. He's a good friend, so that's why you laugh. And he's got these jokes that are brilliant, but nobody cares.
房间里没人笑，只有费尔德曼和我，从旁边看着。没什么比另一个喜剧演员在舞台上出丑更可笑的了，真的。何塞浑身湿透地走下来。费尔德曼走出去，尝试做政治材料。拜托，这些家伙不投票。他们一辈子都在监狱里。我这辈子从来没笑得这么开心过。从来没有。看着费尔德曼，我简直笑得肚子痛。他是个好朋友，这就是为什么你会笑。他有这些精彩的笑话，但没人关心。
And then, not only, to add insult to injury, they start throwing things. They have these bags they're throwing, milk cartons they're throwing. And I'm watching from the side. And he's just dodging. Occasionally he'd glance at me. I'm down on one knee laughing so hard that then he'd start laughing, causing them, I guess, to hate him more. And they'd throw more stuff. It was an ugly cycle there.
然后，不仅如此，更糟糕的是，他们开始扔东西。他们扔袋子，扔牛奶盒。我从旁边看着。他只是在躲闪。偶尔他会瞥我一眼。我跪在地上笑得太厉害了，然后他也开始笑，这让他更招人恨，我想。他们扔得更多了。那里是一个丑陋的循环。
Feldman comes off. He can't even look at me.  He's staring down, just shaking his head. They announce my name. I drift toward the stage in a surreal haze. I have to be up there for 45 minutes. And I took the mic out of the stand, and moved the stand over, and this vitriolic bile is being spewed at me. And I know if I try my act, they will eat me alive.
费尔德曼下来了。他甚至不敢看我。他盯着下面，直摇头。他们宣布了我的名字。我在超现实的迷雾中漂向舞台。我必须在那里呆45分钟。我把麦克风从支架上拿出来，把支架移到一边，这种恶毒的胆汁正在喷向我。我知道如果我尝试我的表演，他们会活吞了我。
So I'm wondering what to say. And in my indecisiveness there, I think they took that for some sort of professionalism, and they started to get quiet. And when they were totally quiet, I lifted the mic and I said, "I just got back from K block, and boy, is my ass sore." Baaaaah! I had the hugest laugh I have ever-- just baaaaaah! They're just roaring with laughter for about a minute.
所以我不知道该说什么。在我的优柔寡断中，我想他们把那误认为某种专业精神，他们开始安静下来。当他们完全安静时，我举起麦克风说：“我刚从K区回来，天哪，我的屁股好痛。”哇！这是我听到过的最大的笑声——哇！他们哄堂大笑大约一分钟。
And while they're laughing, I notice that the entire side over here-- these two bleachers, all black men. These two bleachers, all white men. Without exception. So I look at one of these white guys, then I go, excuse me, sir. If your dick was big enough, could you sit with the black guys? Baaaaaah! Now the black guys are high-fiving. They're crying. I'm a god in the slammer all of a sudden.
当他们笑的时候，我注意到这整边——这两个看台，全是黑人。这两个看台，全是白人。无一例外。所以我看着其中一个白人家伙，然后我说：“不好意思，先生。如果你的那玩意儿够大，你能和黑人伙计们坐在一起吗？”哇！现在黑人伙计们在击掌。他们流着泪。我突然成了监狱里的神。
And I notice a black guy in the front row, hair in curlers. So I walk over and I say, where are you going tomorrow that you need to look better than tonight, the big social event of your year?
我注意到前排有个黑人，头发卷着发卷。所以我走过去说：“你明天要去哪儿，需要看起来比今晚还好，这是你一年中最重要的社交活动吗？”
Well, from then on, I'm solid gold. Everything works. At one point, I said, I'm sorry my voice is a little hoarse. I just vomited up a bag of heroin for a friend here. I started talking about how my third dad had been in prison. Some guy in the back yells, yeah, I knew him. So I looked at him, I said, you know, you look familiar. I think your face is tattooed on his ass. And some really fat ugly guy right here starts giving me [BLEEP]. I have everybody move 10 feet away from him, and then I order the guards to shoot him. At one point, I actually started taunting the inmates. I got off of the stage, right behind the yellow line, took out my wallet a $20 bill, and I said, come get it, pussies.
好吧，从那以后，我就是纯金的。一切都奏效了。有一次，我说：“抱歉我的声音有点沙哑。我刚为这里的一个朋友吐出了一袋海洛因。”我开始谈论我的第三任父亲曾经在监狱里。后面有个家伙大喊：“是的，我认识他。”所以我看着他说：“你知道，你看上去很面熟。我觉得你的脸纹在他屁股上了。”然后这儿有个又胖又丑的家伙开始给我［被哔］。我让大家离他远10英尺，然后我命令警卫开枪打死他。有一次，我实际上开始嘲弄囚犯。我走下舞台，就在黄线后面，拿出我的钱包和一张20美元钞票，我说：“来拿啊，胆小鬼。”
I ended the night with a Christmas song-along. Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way. Only the rapists now! Let's go! Oh what fun it is to ride in a one horse open sleigh. Child molesters, join on in!
我以圣诞歌合唱结束了夜晚。“铃儿响叮当，铃儿响叮当，铃儿响叮当……现在只有强奸犯！我们走！在单马拉的雪橇上，多么快乐！猥亵儿童者，也加入进来！”
Rick Reynolds, telling a story from his one-man show, All Grown Up and No Place to Go. It's on a CD from Rhino Records.
瑞克·雷诺兹，讲述了他个人秀《全都长大了，无处可去》中的一个故事。它在犀牛唱片公司发行的CD上。
[MUSIC - "IN THE JAILHOUSE, NOW" BY STEVE EARLE AND THE V-ROYS]
［音乐 - 史蒂夫·厄尔和V-Roys乐队的《现在在监狱里》］
Act Five, Color Bar.
第五幕，“色条”。
How are we changed by prison? Breyten Breytenbach was incarcerated for seven years by the apartheid government of South Africa. He was caught reentering the country on his way to work with the political resistance during the apartheid regime. He's a painter and a writer.
我们是如何被监狱改变的？布雷顿·布雷滕巴赫被南非种族隔离政府监禁了七年。他在重返该国准备在种族隔离政权下与政治抵抗组织合作时被捕。他是一名画家和作家。
In some ways, his time in prison was different from most American incarcerations. In one facility he was in, the prisoners sang each night from their cells. But in other ways, what happened to him is what's happened to many people, everywhere, over the centuries, when left in confinement.
在某些方面，他的监狱时光与大多数美国人的监禁不同。在他待过的一个设施里，囚犯们每晚在牢房里唱歌。但在其他方面，发生在他身上的事情与几个世纪以来世界各地的人在被关押时发生的事情是一样的。
For the first two years in prison, I was kept in a very small area all by myself. So I literally had very little to see or to look at in terms of variety, in terms of what one had become used to. You know what I see normally is seeing people come and go, in different distances, and different colors, and different lights. That was all just one very gray soup. Never seeing further than, say, about six feet away from me. The cell was 13 feet by 6 feet. So that was the limit of one's field of vision. And there was no variety in that field of vision, either.
在监狱的前两年，我一直独自待在一个非常小的区域里。所以实际上我几乎没什么可看、没什么可观察的，就多样性而言，就人们习惯的东西而言。你知道我通常看到的是人来人往，不同的距离，不同的颜色，不同的光线。那全是一碗灰色的浓汤。从未看过离我超过六英尺远的地方。牢房是13英尺乘6英尺。所以这就是一个人视野的极限。而且那个视野里也没有多样性。
And of course, one was suffering inevitably from vitamin deficiency. So that one's eyesight was going down all the time. And I hadn't been aware of it. In fact, I remember I became aware of this when they transported me from the Pretoria prison to the Cape Town prison, which took place in a closed truck. And it had an air vent that was slightly open. And I could peek through there and see the landscape going by. And I suddenly realized that my eyesight was shot, gone.
当然，一个人不可避免地遭受维生素缺乏。所以一个人的视力一直在下降。我并没有意识到这一点。事实上，我记得当我被从比勒陀利亚监狱运送到开普敦监狱时，我意识到了这一点，这是在一辆封闭的卡车里进行的。它有一个稍微打开的通风口。我可以从那里偷看外面经过的风景。我突然意识到我的视力完了，没了。
The irredeemable or the unstoppable wearing away that time has on one in prison is a very strong awareness. You know that you are being changed without being able to measure the extent of the changes that are taking place. You know that that this is a process of degradation taking place. But since you have nothing against which to measure this, you can not fight it. And at the same time, you have no sense of time passing at all, because there's nothing to which to tie it. It's like water. It runs right through you.
时间在监狱里对一个人造成的不可救药的或不可阻挡的磨损是一种非常强烈的意识。你知道你正在改变，却无法衡量正在发生的变化的程度。你知道这是一个正在发生的退化过程。但因为你没有任何东西来衡量它，你无法对抗它。同时，你根本没有时间流逝的感觉，因为没有任何东西可以把它关联起来。它就像水。它直接穿过你。
The one particular prison that I have in mind now, called Beverly Hills-- we called it Beverly Hills, in Pretoria. It's the hanging jail. It's where they execute people. Up to about 200 a year. Now, that has as its central characteristic the actual chamber, the room where people are executed.
我现在想到那个特别的监狱，叫“比佛利山庄”——我们在比勒陀利亚叫它“比佛利山庄”。那是绞刑监狱。那是他们执行死刑的地方。每年多达200人。现在，它的核心特征是那个实际的刑室，执行死刑的房间。
But if you live in that prison, you never see it. You're intensely aware of it. You know it's there. You can hear it. You can hear the room, because you can hear the trapdoors opening. There is sort of this shuddering going through the building when people actually are being hanged in the morning. And then you hear the coffins being put together.
但如果你住在那座监狱里，你永远看不到它。你强烈地意识到它的存在。你知道它在那里。你可以听到它。你可以听到那个房间，因为你可以听到活板门打开的声音。当人们早上真的被绞死时，建筑物里有一种颤抖。然后你可以听到棺材被组装起来的声音。
Hearing this room, or this enclosure, without actually seeing it, makes it a very mysterious heart of the place. So you really have the sense of being in a labyrinth. I think it's a real way in which the senses merge there. You literally see with your ears. Because I think that when you hear those sounds, that was your thread out of the labyrinth, in a sense.
听到这个房间，或者这个封闭区，而实际上看不到它，使它成为这个地方非常神秘的心脏。所以你真的有一种身处迷宫的感觉。我认为那里的感官确实融合在一起了。你实际上是用耳朵看的。因为我认为当你听到那些声音时，在某种意义上，那是你走出迷宫的线索。
That was the way you learned about what other people were doing. The quality also of what they were involved in. Because you could sense, you could hear the quality of their voices change when they knew that they were going to be hanged in a week's time. It was definitely-- you could hear, when somebody sang that that person is going to die in a few days, as opposed to somebody else singing who probably still has two months or three months.
那是你了解其他人正在做什么的方式。这也是他们所卷入事情的性质。因为你可以感觉到，你可以听到他们声音的变化，当他们知道自己一周内将被绞死时。它绝对是——你可以听到，当一个人唱歌时，那个人几天内就要死了，这与另一个可能还有两个月或三个月时间的人唱歌形成了对比。
And sometimes if it was only one person due to be hanged, he would sing all by himself, in the middle of the night. And then it would be very sad, because it would be much more of a melodic kind of a blues. The interesting thing, or the touching thing about that, is that when that happened, when one person sings all by himself in the middle of the night, due to be hanged in a day or two days' time, you can actually hear the quality of the listening of the other people. Because you know that everybody else in that prison is awake, lying there, listening to this [INAUDIBLE]. And everybody is giving him a chance to sing his song, as it were. You knew there would not be a single person who would be asleep then. You would actually hear people listening, lying with their ears close to the bars or to the walls.
有时如果只有一个人要被绞死，他会在半夜独自唱歌。然后那会非常悲伤，因为它更像是一种旋律优美的蓝调。有趣的事情，或者说感人之处在于，当这种情况发生时，当一个人在半夜独自唱歌，一两天内将被绞死时，你实际上可以听到其他人倾听的品质。因为你知道那座监狱里的每个人都醒着，躺在那里，听着这个［听不清］。每个人都在给他唱歌的机会。你知道那时不会有一个人睡着。你实际上会听到人们倾听，耳朵贴在栏杆或墙壁上。
Desperately trying to communicate. Not because one wanted to alert people to the condition you were in, but you wanted to alert people to the fact that you were still alive. Because you doubted whether you were still alive. You suddenly realized, but life's going on outside there. Even the people who were the closest to you are continuing their lives. They must do that. You know, you went down the road to buy some cigarettes, and you just didn't come back again. And people wept and moaned for some time, but then life is such that we must go on. So they bowled around the absence and they go on. And they remember your birthday, perhaps, if [UNINTELLIGIBLE], or Christmas. And correspondingly, you stop existing, since in any event, you can not communicate.
拼命地试图沟通。不是因为你想提醒人们你所处的状况，而是你想提醒人们你还活着。因为你怀疑自己是否还活着。你突然意识到，但外面的生活还在继续。即使是离你最近的人也在继续他们的生活。他们必须这样做。你知道，你出门去买点烟，结果就再没回来。人们哀悼了一阵，但生活就是这样，我们必须继续。所以他们绕过你的缺席，继续前进。他们会记得你的生日，也许，如果［听不清］，或者圣诞节。相应地，你停止存在，因为无论如何，你无法沟通。
That was a terrible feeling, of really feeling that one was dead. Particularly since you were cut off from the outside world. And you weren't aware what was happening outside. Then when messages did come in, you would experience them as messages from the other side of the grave, another life. Another life.
那是一种可怕的感觉，真正感到自己已经死了。特别是由于你与外界隔绝。你不知道外面发生了什么。然后当消息传进来时，你会把它们当作来自坟墓另一端、另一个生命的消息。另一个生命。
I remember talking to friends in prison, saying, you know, will we meet again in 10 years' time. And we mustn't forget then what it was like now. The fear that you would lose some of the things you did or were taught in prison, or you learned in prison. We knew that, for instance, as you move away from the experience, the bad parts become obliterated. And you will loop back upon it sometimes even with some nostalgia. It was nice. We were all young together in prison.
我记得在监狱里和朋友交谈，说，你知道，我们十年后还会见面吗？那时候我们绝不能忘记现在是什么样。担心你会失去你在监狱里做过的一些事情，或者被教导的东西，或者你在监狱里学到的东西。我们知道，例如，当你远离那种经历时，糟糕的部分会变得模糊。你会偶尔甚至带着一些怀旧之情回想它。那很好。我们在监狱里一起度过了年轻时光。
That's the way the human mind works, I think. It's always hiding. It always moves away from the tender, from the raw, which is nice, which is fine. That means one dies in glory, I'm sure, thinking that you've had a wonderful life and there has just been one big muck-up.
我想这就是人类思维工作的方式。它总是隐藏。它总是从脆弱、原始的东西中走开，这很好，没问题。这意味着一个人死得光荣，我肯定，想着你有一个美妙的生活，只是发生了一次大混乱。
The colors in prison-- all the no-colors of public places. All sad public places, such as army camps and, I suppose, hospitals during the war years, and things like that. In other words, you see gray. You see metal colors. You see a kind of an off-green. With a bit of luck, you may see a bit of brown. But mostly it's infinite shades of gray and dirty green. We call it in French [SPEAKING FRENCH].
监狱里的颜色——所有公共场所的“无色”。所有悲伤的公共场所，比如陆军营地，我想，战争年代的医院，诸如此类。换句话说，你看到灰色。你看到金属色。你看到一种灰绿色。幸运的话，你可能会看到一点棕色。但主要是无限的灰色和脏绿色。我们在法语里称之为［法语词汇］。
It's like if you deprive somebody of colors for a certain time, and then you introduce color, however small the area of color may be that you introduce, there will be an intense sort of a pang of recognition of that color. A real experience of that color. We live in a surfeit of colors every day. We no longer even notice. We're sitting, looking at pink roses on the wallpaper, you know? The white cover over a bed, or the darkness of a shirt, or whatever it is. These are so much part, we are washed over with the richness of colors all the time. But in a situation like that, when all of a sudden there's this eruption of a toffee wrapper, for instance, or a leaf that got blown over the wall, or even a thread that somehow got blown into the wall, a thread of material, blue, something like that, you can not possibly imagine the intense awareness experience of that color, as if you'd never seen color before.
就像如果你在一段时间内剥夺某人的颜色，然后你引入颜色，无论你引入的颜色区域有多小，都会有一种强烈的认出那种颜色的阵痛。一种对那种颜色的真实体验。我们每天生活在颜色的过剩中。我们甚至不再注意了。我们坐着，看着墙纸上的粉红玫瑰，你知道吗？床上的白色床罩，或者衬衫的颜色，或者其他什么。这些都是我们的一部分，我们一直被丰富的颜色所冲刷。但在那样的情况下，当突然间出现了一个太妃糖包装纸，或者一片被吹过墙的叶子，甚至是一根不知怎么被吹进墙里的线，一种材料的线，蓝色的，类似那样的东西，你根本无法想象那种颜色的强烈意识体验，就好像你以前从没见过颜色一样。
It makes of you a very nervous, very tight person when you're out of prison. Because you're ultra-sensitive to sounds and colors and things like that. They become too much. There were too many colors when I came out. I couldn't take it all in at the same time.
当你出狱时，这会使你成为一个非常紧张、非常紧绷的人。因为你对声音、颜色和诸如此类的事情超级敏感。它们变得太多了。我出来的时候颜色太多了。我无法同时接受所有这些。
And it also gave me a strange sense of superiority. I felt like I was moving into a world of zombies. Now, that is a complete turnabout. In prison, you know that you're living among zombies, because you yourself have become a zombie. I mean, that is what a long-term prison sentence does to you in due time.
这也给我一种奇怪的优越感。我觉得我正在走进一个僵尸的世界。现在，那是一个完全的转变。在监狱里，你知道你生活在僵尸中间，因为你自己已经变成了僵尸。我的意思是，这就是长期监禁最终对你所做的事情。
And yet, when you come out you have a composite feeling of, you're moving among zombies. These people don't really know what life's about. They don't feel walking in the street. They don't see the colors. And they don't know what implications are. They don't feel the people coming up to them. They have no sense of that. They're not alive. Their antennae are not vibrating. And of course, particularly, they're not even aware of the moral implications of what it's like to be walking on the street, a free person. That puts you really out of step with the people whom you move among.
然而，当你出来时，你有一种综合的感觉，你正在僵尸中间移动。这些人真的不知道生活是什么。他们在大街上走时没有任何感觉。他们看不见颜色。他们不知道暗示是什么。他们感觉不到走近他们的人。他们没有那种感觉。他们不活着。他们的天线没有在振动。当然，特别是，他们甚至没有意识到在大街上行走作为一个自由人是什么感觉的道德含义。这让你和你周围的人完全脱节。
Breyten Breytenbach was originally taped for a radio series called Territories of Art for the Museum of Contemporary Art in Los Angeles in 1986. He was recorded by Stephen Erickson and interviewed by Lawrence Weschler, who used the interviews in writing about Breytenbach for his book Calamities of Exile. Breytenbach himself recounts his experiences in his book, True Confessions of an Albino Terrorist.
布雷顿·布雷滕巴赫最初于1986年为洛杉矶当代艺术博物馆的广播系列《艺术领土》录音。他由斯蒂芬·埃里克森录音，并由劳伦斯·韦施勒采访，韦施勒在他关于布雷滕巴赫的书《流亡的灾难》中使用了这些采访。布雷滕巴赫本人在他的书《白化恐怖分子的真实供词》中讲述了他的经历。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel, Julie Snyder, and Emi Takahara. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann.
好吧，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我，以及阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、朱莉·斯奈德和江美高原制作。贡献编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。托德·巴克曼提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
［致谢］
If you would like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, they make perfect Christmas presents. And my friend, we are running a Christmas special. The phone number here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Our website address, www.thisamericanlife.com.
如果你想购买这个或我们任何节目的磁带，它们是完美的圣诞礼物。我的朋友，我们正在进行圣诞特价。芝加哥WBEZ的电话号码，312-832-3380。我们的网站地址，www.thisamericanlife.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
［资助说明］
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who insists that you call him--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他坚持让你叫他——
The jocker, man, pitcher, or daddy.
“jocker”、“男人”、“投手”或“爸爸”。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。